Sal: --the consistent theme
we're discovering in
chemistry, that everything
is about random
bumps between molecules.
And when they bump randomly
into each other, a lot of
different things can happen in
terms of knocking different
parts of the molecules off of
each other and bonding to
different things.
This includes pure water, which
for the most part, one
would think is a pretty
stable substance.
And it really is.
But it turns out-- let's
say if we start
with 2 water molecules.
And when I put a 2 here, and any
of these is going to turn
into an equilibrium equation.
It could represent 2 molecules,
it could represent
2 moles of molecules.
What matters is just the ratios
in these equations.
And I think you know that.
But let me just draw
2 for an example.
So let's say I have
the oxygen end.
Let's have another
oxygen here.
They both are attached
to some hydrogens.
They're sharing electrons with
some hydrogens here.
And we know that oxygen is a lot
more electronegative than
hydrogen, so it hogs all of the
electrons and what that
creates is a partial positive
charge at the hydrogen side of
the water molecule.
They're almost naked protons
being attached
to the water molecules.
This is positive here.
And then the oxygen sides have
a partial negative charge
because they're hogging
all the electrons.
And this bond between the
negative side of the oxygen
molecules and the positive
side of another oxygen
molecule-- this is called a
hydrogen bond-- this is what
keeps water together and what
keeps it definitely in it's
liquid or solid states.
And in solid states, these bonds
become-- they only stay
together in some lattice
structure.
And in a liquid state, they
can kind of break
and form new ones.
But they keep them close to each
other, rubbing against
each other.
Now it turns out if you just
have exactly the right set of
circumstances-- this isn't the
exact some circumstances, but
I think you can imagine.
If this moved just exactly close
enough, it had enough
kinetic energy to move right
past this one, there's some
probability-- and I'll draw an
equilibrium reaction here,
because that is what we
are dealing with.
The equilibrium reaction.
There's some probability that
this hydrogen right here gets
stuck to this guy.
He gets so close, and maybe this
guy bounces in some other
weird way that we get left
with-- let me draw the same 2
characters, the 2 oxygens.
Actually let, me draw
the second guy.
Let's say that he just he just
somehow passed the other guy.
So he had some movement.
Let's say he moved in
that direction.
This is obviously is not
scientific, but it gives you a
narrative around what
could happen.
This guy's hydrogen protons.
And this was attracted
to this oxygen side.
And if just under the right
circumstances-- Remember.
Everything here is
probabalistic.
There's always a probability of
almost anything happening.
This guy can get attached to
the negative side of this
water molecule, the
water side.
And then this guy is only left
with one hydrogen right here.
And then this molecule as a
whole, this is OH, hydroxide.
And it has a minus
charge, right?
Because water was a
neutral molecule.
You had just as many protons
and electrons.
Now we have 1 less proton
than electrons.
So in this case, just the
hydrogen nucleus itself--
which is just a proton because
we learned that hydrogen
doesn't have any neutrons
in it's normal form.
This is essentially a proton
when we draw a hydrogen.
It gets bumped off or scraped
off and ends up on this water
molecule, so this guy lost
a proton, has the
same number of electrons.
So he now has a negative
charge.
This guy has the same number of
electrons, but now he's got
an extra proton.
So he has a positive charge.
So this is H3O with
a positive charge.
And this little version right
here where we gave a water
molecule and it somehow gains
an extra hydrogen proton or
hydrogen atom.
This is called hydronium.
And this process where water
can kind of spontaneously--
and I'm not saying that water--
you know, a whole
glass of water, this
is going to happen.
It's actually happening
to a very
small number of molecules.
That if you view this is an
equilibrium reaction-- when
you have 2 waters, the reaction
is much more weighted
in the leftward direction.
But this can happen, and that's
what the whole point of
this is to think about.
But this process is called
autoionization.
Because you just have water by
itself, and just buy some
random circumstances of some
molecules bumping into each
other just right, some
subset of the water
will ionize like this.
Where one part will lose
a proton and the other
part will gain one.
So this is autoionization.
And of course this is an
equilibrium reaction, so now
these guys might go
bump into 2 other
things and become water.
Maybe they'll bump into
each other again and
they'll become water.
So goes back and forth.
So there's some equilibrium
concentration of this.
Let me write it as a proper
equilibrium reaction.
So you could have 2, maybe
moles of water molecules.
They are in equilibrium
with H3O positive.
And all these are in an
aqueous solution.
And that's a bit of a redundancy
because aqueous
solution means that you're
dissolved in water.
So of course water is
But then H3O dissolved
in water.
So all around here, you
have water molecules.
This isn't isolation.
You have gazillions of water
molecules all around.
Plus OH minus aqueous.
Now.
Sometimes you'll see that exact
reaction written as this.
And it's important if you
realize it's the same thing.
H2O in equilibrium with just
1 hydrogen ion popping off.
Everything's in an
aqueous solution.
Let me write that down.
Everything is being dissolved
and water.
Plus OH minus in an aqueous
solution And this equation
right here-- and what
I wrote at the top.
And let me cut and paste
this so you can see
them at the same time.
Copy.
Go down here.
And paste this.
These are essentially
equivalent, although the
second equation right
here describes
what exactly happens.
So the first equation is
creating a picture.
You have one water molecule
and there's some small
probability that one of its
hydrogens just pop off.
And you're just left with a
hydrogen and a hydroxide,
which is just an oxygen and
a hydrogen atom together.
But the reality is that these
hydrogen protons don't exist
in water on their own.
Whenever they are in water, in
an aqueous solution, they
essentially get a ride with
another water molecule.
And that's what happens here
with the hydronium ion.
But the whole reason why I'm
going into this whole
discussion about the
autoionization of water is
because people really care about
the concentration of--
depending on how I view it--
hydrogen atoms, hydrogen
protons in a solution, or you
could say hydronium protons in
a solution.
The concentration of
these 2 things are
going to be the same.
Right?
Because all of these really are
riding on another water
molecule and becoming
hydronium.
How do you measure this-- or a
better question is what is the
equilibrium of this reaction?
So it turns out that in just
regular water, the
concentration-- and I'll maybe
I'll switch to this one.
The concentration of-- this
is in regular water
at 25 degrees Celsius.
Let me write that down.
25 degrees Celsius, which is
roughly room temperature.
With pure water.
The concentration
of pure water.
In pure water, the concentration
of hydrogen
ions, and you could also say
that that's the concentration
of hydronium ions, or cations,
because they're positive.
It equals 10 to the minus
seventh molar.
Right?
So for every 1 liter of water,
you have 10 to the minus 7
moles of hydronium ions.
Which is still a pretty good
number because it's 10 to the
minus 7 moles, so it's
10 to the minus 7
times Avogadro's number.
So let me just do that.
So it's 10 to the minus 7 moles
per liter of water,
which is the same thing as 10 to
the minus 7 times-- a mole
is just a number.
6.022 times 10 to the 23.
So you do the math here.
You still end up with what?
60 times 10 to the 16th
power molecule.
So you still have a large
number of molecules.
It's just a small fraction of
the total number molecules are
actually these hydrogen or
these hydronium ions.
And it turns out that your
concentration of hydroxides is
also-- so your concentration
of hydroxides is also 10 to
the minus seventh molars.
So if we know that, we can now
actually figure out the
equilibrium constant for this
autoionization of water.
We can figure out the
equilibrium constant.
So let's do that.
And we'll do it with
the first one.
So let's say you have--
I'll switch colors.
H2O in an aqueous solution.
It's in equilibrium
with hydrogen ions
in an aqueous solution.
But we know in reality
they've gotten rides
with other water ions.
With the other water molecules,
not ions.
They turn them into
hydronium ions.
Plus hydroxide molecule.
The equilibrium for this
reaction, the equilibrium
constant, we'll call it for
the K sub w for water.
It equals the concentration of
the products of hydrogen ions
times a concentration of
the hydroxide ions.
Now, in a normal situation,
we would divide it by the
concentration of
the reactants.
But in this case, and we learned
this before, the
reactants are what
the solvent is.
We are in water.
So you we won't include this.
And if you want the intuition
behind that, remember this
whole thing comes out from the
probability of-- this is the
probably of the backwards
reaction happening as related
to the concentrations
of these two things
multiplied by each other.
And the probably the forward
reaction happening is related
to the probability of finding
two of the product-- of the
reacting molecules
in one space.
And you're always going
to find these
molecules in some place.
It's just going to be a constant
probability that some
water spontaneously turns
into these two products.
So whenever you have a reaction
like this equilibrium
reaction, and the one side is
essentially just a solution,
you just don't include it.
So the equilibrium-- or you
could just think of
it as a 1 down here.
So the equilibrium constant of
this autoionization water is
right there.
And I just gave you what the
numbers were at room
temperature.
So the equilibrium constant is
equal to-- the concentration
of hydrogen is 10 to the minus
7 times a concentration of
hydroxide is also 10
to the minus 7.
So it equals 10 to the
minus 14th power.
Now.
And that's a good thing
to memorize.
The equilibrium constant of the
autoionization of water.
And just so you know, this is
all going to lead into acids.
Because essentially people care
a whole bunch about what
this concentration
ends up being.
And we're going to
touch on that a
little bit in this video.
Now it turns out that people
chemistry, for whatever
reason, they don't like talking
in these terms. They
don't like saying 10 to
the minus 14th power.
So what they do is they take
the negative log of things.
Negative log base 10.
And if logs are intimidating to
you, review the videos on
logarithms.
So what they do is they take the
minus log of both sides.
And when someone just writes log
without a number, you can
assume it's base 10.
But they take the minus log of
the equilibrium constant.
The minus log base 10 of 10 to
the minus 14 is equal to--
well 10 to what powers is
10 to the minus 14?
Well, it's minus fourteen,
right?
And then you have that
minus in front.
You have this minus, and the
log part is just minus 14.
And so the minus log of the
equilibrium constant of water
is equal to 14.
And this idea right here
is called a pKw.
pK.
Let me put the p in a different
color just so you
see where it's-- pKw.
But all p means, whenever you
see it in chemistry, it just
means minus log base 10.
Minus log base 10.
And there's some debate as to
what p stands for, I try to
think of it as power, although
it's a minus log, it's a
exponent-- but whatever.
It means you're taking the
minus log of something.
And what it does is, it's just a
way kind of a way to get out
of the exponent world-- although
I think it's nicer to
stay in the exponent world
because you really know what
you're talking about--
into some nice
clean number like 14.
So when someone says that's
the pKw is 14, all they're
saying is that the equilibrium
constant, which is just this
part right here, is 10
to the minus 14.
Now, the same convention
is used on the hydrogen
concentration.
The next few videos are all
going to revolve around the
hydrogen concentration in
water, essentially.
We'll talk a little bit about
what happens when you're
outside of water.
Now the hydrogen concentration
of water at room temperature,
I've told you, has been
determined to be 10 to the
minus 7 molars.
People aren't happy just with
that, so what they want to do
is do the same thing.
They want to take the minus
log of both sides.
So they say that pH--
and you've probably
heard the word pH.
It's a lot of cosmetics.
pH balance.
Now you know what it means.
They're really just saying that
we have the right number
of hydrogen ions in our lotion
or our perfume or whatever
we're trying to sell you.
So the pH is equal to the minus
log of the hydrogen ion
concentration, which is equal
to the minus log, remember,
it's just a base 10 if I don't
specify otherwise, of 10 to
the minus 7, which is equal to--
well, 10 to what power is
10 to the minus 7?
This is equal to minus 7.
Then we have the minus
outside, so then
this becomes 7.
Now.
You can do that same exercise
for the pOH.
pOH.
The concentration of
hydroxide ions.
What's the negative log of the
hydroxide concentration.
The hydroxide concentration,
we saw, was the same
concentration as the water
concentration.
Oh, I didn't write it there.
Where did I write it?
Right there.
10 of the minus seventh
molars.
So water has the same
number of hydroxides
and hydrogen ions.
And that's because this water
is just associating into the
two of them.
But of course this is equal
to minus 7, right?
Log-based.
This number right here
is 10 to the minus 7.
So it equals 7.
So the pH and the pOH of water
is both equal to 7.
Now.
In the next few videos, we're
going to start covering the
notion of acids and bases.
And it turns out that an acid
is just something that
increases the hydrogen
concentration.
Well, that's one version
of acids.
We'll talk about other
broader definitions.
But it's called the
arrhenius acid.
Which we'll talk about
in the next video.
But if something is making the
hydrogen concentration go up,
if we put something in water
that makes it go up, what's
that going to do the pH?
Well, if this number right here
goes up, then the log of
that number is going to go up.
But then the minus log
of that number--
So let's say for example
10 to the minus 7.
That's all good.
But let's say we take it
from 10 to the minus 7.
So 10 to minus 7, that's
kind of neutral
water, doing nothing.
We have a pH.
The pH is 7.
We just figured out
this calculation.
That's where the hydrogen
concentration is equal to 10
to minus 7.
Now let's say we were to do
something to the water where
the hydrogen concentration
were to increase.
So we add hydrogen.
We add concentration
of hydrogen.
So let's say 10 to
the minus 3.
This is obviously a much
higher concentration of
hydrogen than that.
So the hydrogen concentration
is now 10 to the minus 3.
What's our new pH?
So the new pH is going to be
equal to the minus log base 10
of 10 to the minus 3.
That's equal to that
minus there.
10 to the minus 3 power is equal
to 10 to the minus 3.
So it's minus 3.
So this becomes plus.
So now our pH is equal to 3.
So the big take-away from this
is we care about the hydrogen
concentration.
When something increases the
hydrogen concentration, that
is considered an acid.
And when you increase the
hydrogen concentration, when
you put an acid into an aqueous
solution, you are
lowering the pH.
So the lower the pH, the more
acidic you have, or the higher
concentration of hydrogen
protons you have. And we'll
talk in the next video about the
opposite of that, which is
which is basic things.
And bases increase the
concentration of hydroxide.
Anyway, see you in
the next video.